your your personality your brand is so
much a part of your company's brand and
everything else too I mean so how have
you how have you thought about that I
mean we're right now we're being filmed
by your daily video show do you rock
d-roc is back there daily be C how do
you think about all that if you're kind
of building you up your own personal
brand everything out there - it'll have
different levers right like I didn't
basically here's what I do for a living
I'd a trade attention so what I do for a
living is like day trade and user
attention that's how I launched an
e-commerce website in 1996 even though
that I had no tech skills and really
even knew what the hell I was doing the
only thing I knew was that where people
were gonna buy things on the Internet
and so that was the macro-level
and then basically email newsletter and
Google AdWords and YouTube content and
Twitter and Facebook and LinkedIn
content has out you know you said to me
earlier you were so nice when I first
reached out you were in right away
I was laughing because I was like of
course you had one of the biggest
platforms in the world around the
context of business I want to be there
in that space to me that was the easiest
yes of my life well I remember it was
like a Friday afternoon I called you up
we were talking about the imposter
program we first launched this you were
I think I got like two sentences out
you're like I'm in I do this all the
time and I started spamming him I was
like I was like 100% and so the reason
the you know to me I've been watching
snapchat for three years and only in
January did I start getting really loud
of like this is gonna work to me there
is no doubt that snapchat is that scale
and we'll be at scale for mainstream
because there's a network effect at a
certain scale and so I am very good
intuition on what everybody in this room
is gonna do a lot of times before they
even realize they're gonna do it that's
my core thing that's what I've got and
now I'm trying to scale it and the
reason I decided to hide in my career to
take a step back and eat [ __ ] and build
a client service business was because I
needed to scale the one thing I had and
that's not what I have now I have a 600
person for office 100 million dollar
revenue business that scales my
capability as a human to understand
really had a day trade attention and
know when something's overpriced or
under priced in the world of social
media 24 months ago when everybody was
crying about Facebook organic reach and
Wow
they pulled the rug from underneath us
and this is so bad and don't do it
anymore I knew as a practitioner that
the best ad product that I've seen since
early Google AdWords was being built and
so and then I became a practitioner in
it I'm a practitioner in snapchat the
reason I do snapchat stories I want to
be a practitioner YouTube was something
I was on so early that I took it for
granted and I realized I had to get my
game back on and so that's why I do
content because I'm learning through my
own consecration and then I have my own
like spiel
the reason I do dailyvee is because I
spew a lot about hustle and I realize
crap I don't think people really realize
that I am fundamentally out working
everybody so basically this is just
propaganda to stick it to everybody that
I work harder than the other thing about
being good at this is you get the
i-told-you-so moments right like I love
the clip when I was on with Piers Morgan
saying that Facebook stole Instagram for
a billion dollars which led to 10,000
tweets that I was in the idiot because a
lot of you remember was only 500 days
that Instagram was in business and it
was like a billion it's crazy that it
wasn't that long ago but a billion for
that seemed like outer space and the
same thing with snapchat I've been on
snapchat very aggressively since 2013
what got me to pay attention or the
moment was tens of millions of people
were using it like this is like the
funniest thing like nothing bothers me
more than when people set first guru but
ii ii is futurist or disruptor I think
I'm the most practical operator and
marketer in the world I just mark it for
the day we actually live in right now
not yesterday not tomorrow
so do I know VR or after school or
musically or emerging and things will
happen of course but do I think it's the
best use of every dollar and hour right
now no I do not and so I that's what I
do so I watch snapchat every day and
then 9 10 months ago I'm like okay this
is really hitting critical mass and then
when I watched the first week of what
was happening with dj khaled I was like
okay this is millions this is millions
of people
this this isn't the tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands that I thought
people were getting from snapchat this
is three I mean I got a screenshot from
it like three million people I'm like
okay this is now a real true meaningful
scale which means it's not just 13 to 18
and then I just live life right like I
travel so much I started seeing 30 and
40 year old people with a yellow app on
their home screen right like it was
really that basic and then there's the
thing that blows my mind which is
everybody in this room can do what I do
which is wake up in the morning and the
first thing I do grab their phone look
at the app store top hundred free apps
and look at the charts it's just been
sitting there in a top five for [ __ ]
I don't know a year and a half like
that's real data like I'm like there's
no guests I'm not I'm not predicting
musically success it's been a top 20 app
for four and a half months like it's
like this is just this is not a joke
what I'm about to tell you in 2006 when
I was 31 years old I didn't even know
agencies were a thing because the way I
built wine library I did it all myself
direct to the platforms that I was using
I didn't even know that Madison Avenue
advertising agencies existed somebody
came to sell me billboards if you lived
in New Jersey and during that time I
just have billboards of myself up and
talked about nurses there was billboards
of me saying watch the Wine Library TV
show because I literally used to drive
from New York to New Jersey every day
you know like and when the guy sold him
to me I did the creative I gave it back
to him and then he gave me a bill and I
lost my [ __ ] because I didn't know I
thought he worked for CBS Viacom but he
had some hope you know Lopez like media
like he was a Meany agency and who's
charging him like for what like you know
like like I literally didn't even know
there that ecosystem and the truth is my
under education my lack of education my
lack of that has hurt me because I had a
pattern recognized later in my life it's
why I'm gonna win later in my life the
reason I'm not gonna buy the Jets in my
40s and I'm gonna buy him in my 70s is
because I didn't I didn't know when I
put all my personal post tax money into
Twitter and Facebook
this is sad as [ __ ] I'm now 35 I didn't
know that I could go to other human
beings and raise money and take 20% of
the upside if I did I'd already be a
billionaire because I would so like just
think about that just basic something
you could read when you're 11 years old
on the Internet of like carrying money
like basic fun dynamics was something I
didn't know at 35 years old because if I
did I would have raised it made a lot of
people in my world didn't I'm a lot of
money and I would have made 20% the
upside which would have been remarkable
so you know I don't when I say I don't
have mentors I think of that as weakness
but I just know it's my truth and it's
all I got and I'm so ski it's like
meditation meditation is about to
explode in America right like like what
happened with Starbucks and coffee shops
and what happened with SoulCycle and
exercising is one thousand one thousand
percent gonna happen with meditation in
four and a half five years everybody
here is gonna go to the [ __ ]
meditation thing and they're gonna have
their [ __ ] t-shirt so we're all gonna
sit there and it's gonna be at scale
it's a trillion dollar business why do
you say that why because I pay attention
to consumer trends because they had
space because of the couple of studios
in New York in LA because I just know
how [ __ ] works and the only reason I'm
telling you the story right now is to
get it on film
so we can do the recall in four years
and be like I told you and so so if you
want to know why I'm telling you this
story but oh I was trying to figure out
why did I get here besides that I will
never do it I'm so happy and so grateful
for the way I'm hardwired and soft wired
that I'm literally scared to do
meditation cuz I'm scared in my triggers
something in my brain in a different
direction and make me not this 100%
complete happy and it's the same reason
I don't have mentors I know what I'm
doing it's good for me I like it I don't
even want to be affected by other people
I don't want to hear from any [ __ ]
guru I want to watch what you guys do
it's scale and make my decisions and
just
my thing
[Music]